the narrative for the presidential
campaign
flipped on friday after the president's
positive covid test
now the trump campaign has shifted to
virtual events
while joe biden hits the trail joining
us now from minneapolis senator amy
klobuchar a key backer of the former
vice president senator
what are your thoughts about the
president's
illness first of all the fact that the
president and first lady have contracted
covid
and secondly how he's handled kovid over
these last months
well first chris my prayers are with the
president and the first lady
and all of their staff and the
republican senators that we all
we now know are ill and we wish them all
a speedy recovery
i think it was uh joe biden that said
that uh this
should be not about partisanship not
about politics this is an
american moment and to me that means
electing a president that has a plan
instead of pandemonium i think it means
putting a strong leader in place
that number one understands we listen to
the experts
just like the doctor you just had on who
is telling people yes
wear mass in public settings by the way
it'll save a hundred thousand lives
in 100 days you need a plan for
having national testing strategy which
would help us immensely with our
economy so businesses can reopen
um in a very consistent way and then the
third thing
is transparency with contact producing
and the like
and we just haven't seen that we've
heard things like oh this will be done
by easter
oh this will go away with warm weather
oh this is a hoax
this is deeply personal to me chris you
know that my husband was very very sick
had pneumonia was in the hospital for
nearly a week
and it is deeply personal to so many
americans it is now personal to the
president
but it is deeply personal to so many
people and that's why i think you see
in states like florida now you know
since the debate
where people didn't like what they heard
from the president
joe biden's up five points in a poll
yesterday or he's up in pennsylvania
clearly democrats republicans and
independents
want someone that is following the facts
and is going to help
them out and their families and get us
through this pandemic
the senator the biden campaign has taken
down
all of its negative ads but the
president
some republicans are saying that
democrats are still
attacking the president while he's now
in the hospital should
discussions about covert be off limits
at this particular point
well not discussions about covid not
when you had
seven million people get this virus
not when you have people in assisted
living uh who have been isolated
uh for this entire year and moms
juggling their kids on their laps while
they're trying to do their work
and no but i think joe biden has set the
tone here because he's a leader and he
said look
i want the president to be back he wants
to debate him more he
wants him to have a speedy recovery and
so this
isn't about politics or partisanship but
certainly the pandemic the effect that
it has had on people's lives
how they have miscalculated at this
administration
of course that's on the table because as
joe pointed out at the debate
we have 200 000 families right now that
have
a chair at the table that's empty so it
is on the table as well as the economy
and how we can get through the day after
tomorrow
and the kind of leadership you'll need
to make sure we get there
right the issue of how
to campaign during a pandemic came up
during tuesday's debate take a look
senator
i'll have 25 35 000 people show up at
airports
we use airports
well so far we have had no problem
whatsoever it's outside he's been
totally irresponsible the way in which
he has handled
the social distancing and people wearing
masks basically encourage them not
to this raises the whole
question of how to reopen the country
whether it's
reopening and how you conduct the
campaign whether it's reopening the
economy
whether it's reopening schools you just
heard trump campaign adviser
steve cortez say and the president said
in the debate
that joe biden is being too cautious too
much of an alarmist and
is too ready to shut down the government
again
or rather shut down the economy again
excuse me
joe biden has made really clear uh that
he wants to build back better
and he wants to get this economy to a
place where we're actually
expanding and in fact i'd note that
moody is not exactly a liberal
organization
just said that joe biden's plan will add
seven million more jobs next year
than donald trump's plan and so he wants
to do that but he believes you use
science as a guy that's all
and you can see you shouldn't just have
testing for
white house staff we should be able to
have grocery store clerks and
and nurses and first responders they
should be able to have more frequent
testing too
and there is a way to do this but right
now it's just
this idea that oh this is going to get
better we've turned the corner as your
first guest just said
33 states that's the facts the doctor
said them
33 states we've seen increases right now
in the last few weeks
and so what does that mean to me we can
we can get through this
there's so much promising work being
done on vaccines but to get to that
point
we have to have a national testing
strategy and then we also have to have
an economic plan
for what i call the day after tomorrow
so we can get through this
senator senator it turns out that two
of your republican colleagues on the
senate judiciary committee senators
mike lee and tom tillis have now tested
positive for covid
are democrats going to try to use
this as a way to delay the confirmation
hearing and the confirmation vote
on judge barrett
it's not a matter of using it chris it
happened and the first thing we know is
that if you look at the precedent that
mitch mcconnell said
we should let the people decide and
that's where the majority of people
are when it comes to this decide who the
president is
after this election and let them pick
the nominee
secondly we've got the fact that now
three senators have it as you point out
two are on the judiciary committee
and mitch mcconnell has shut the senate
down for two
weeks because of health concerns because
we don't know how many other republican
senators
had it there were a number of other ones
that were at the rose garden
they have a lunch together where they
don't have mass we don't do that on the
democratic side
they do and so it's very possible we're
going to have more senators more staff
so i don't know why you would ram
through this supreme court
hearing put people in danger because it
would be within that two-week period
while you have shut down the whole
senate i just think it's wrong
we are suggesting that they wait
but senator uh the fact is that you can
hold hearings in different ways in fact
last may
uh when the chairman of the judiciary
committee lindsey graham held a virtual
hearing
you very much praised him and thanked
him for doing that
so you could hold a virtual hearing for
uh
for judge barrett which raises the
question again
are you trying to use the fact that
there has been this outbreak
uh at least three republican senators to
try to block a nomination that you
frankly
oppose fiercely
absolutely not this is for the highest
port of the land and yes we have had
virtual hearings um i hope to put them
together it's important to give senators
that option
but you want to be able to go back and
forth with this nominee
given her views on the affordable care
act given that she has
clearly criticized justice roberts who
again
not exactly a blazing liberal for
upholding the constitutional of the
affordable care act which allows people
to keep their insurance
when they've got pre-existing conditions
and she has criticized that
yeah we want to be able but we're doing
we're doing this virtually
senator we're doing this virtually so
why can't you
question judge barrett virtually
again we believe you should have an
in-person hearing that doesn't mean the
virtual option wouldn't be available
but why would you ram i guess i turned
the question around here
even though you get to ask the questions
why would you ram this through
when we don't even have a covid package
done to make sure
that people have health care that we
have the testing i just talked about
that we have the funding for that the
senate republicans have been resisting
this
while nancy pelosi has been valiantly
working on it and the white house now
claims they want a package
why would we be doing this instead of
actually be helping the american people
so that's why i think it is so important
that that's what we do
instead of ramming through a supreme
court justice wait until after the
election better for safety
better for the country senator klobuchar
thank you
thanks for your time this weekend please
come back i will and i did that all
without interrupting you once i would
like to point out chris wallace
[Laughter]
i interrupted you a couple of times it's
a little hard on this skype deal
senator thank you